I hope his extra commitment in the
kitchen is reflected in the standard of
his food
close your eyes and actually count
flavors except walnuts the pasta very
good
I'm pleased to say he's stuck to a small
very simple Italian menu and
everything's freshly cooked this the
kind of food will party rustic wholesome
Italian food rich with tomatoes nice
texture a meatball and a perfectly
cooked linguine lovely me his lecturer
ready
but Alex Scott Alex has come a long way
since these plastic sauces just six
weeks ago last time you're struggling to
sort of live survive depending on credit
cards yeah in the ship yep I mean
Christmas we've basically cheerful like
that sort of business and personal debts
yep starting afresh especially the new
year bank balance even though he's still
got the car
alex has managed to clear 20,000 pounds
worth of debt and can finally afford to
pay himself a wage but there's still one
thing standing in the way of Alex's
success and that's Alex I sincerely hope
he doesn't try to run before he can walk
back in years time and say yes Alex you
are an a.1 yet unfortunately just
ambassador fog bail oh please between
them they've learned how to crack the
egg - [ __ ] piece of very nice but
they haven't yet made the omelet
cooking now for six weeks because that's
all I'm gonna say are you cooking
properly for six weeks and it takes
years you know oh yeah absolutely don't
forget that no no this big wake up call
Kent or Eva just really solve what can
be done
yeah small premises yeah using fresh
ingredients what you're saying is that
you're no longer a [ __ ] cowboy
absolutely so when you think that things
are going perfectly right and you don't
really need to improve think back the
days of powdered stock you always learn
about use of the shits of yourself
because it's good no one here and five
minutes to do that before you do it
yourself
oh yeah we appreciate it thank you just
one last thing before I go
Gary I'm a skort and how are you
maintenance I need a favor I'm a little
bit in the [ __ ] joist now Gary Rose is
truly and ain't one chef I can give it
to you for two thousand nine hundred and
ninety eight pounds